this isn't actually Paul Rudd it's an
action figure of Paul Rudd and it's got
a lot more detail than the action
figures you may be used to you've
probably seen action figures like this
before it's based on a movie has some
accessories and it kind of looks like
the star
I think definitely not an exact
resemblance up until a few years ago
action figures didn't really look like
their movie counterparts that changed
when Hasbro introduced its photo-real
technology in 2017 used on both its
Marvel Legends and star wars black
series lines the technology allows the
company to create figures with faces
that look exactly like the actor they're
based on the figures begin like most
others things like accessories outfits
and points of articulation are all
planned out digitally and a basic sculpt
and molds of the figure are created once
we have a 3d sculpt that we're in love
with that matches our design spec it
gets turned over to the model shop they
will cast it which is a process of
taking the files and growing the files
taking those pieces casting them in
rubber molds so that we can make
duplicates once the duplicates are made
the process of making this plain white
figure looked just like its character
can begin it starts with some pretty
high-res photos of the actor in costume
the photos are provided by the studio in
this case Marvel which works with Hasbro
to make sure they get the photos and
engels they need but for something like
Star Wars which didn't have lifelike
action figures in mind when it began
filming more than 40 years ago so a lot
of it kind of relies on onset
photography especially for kind of
getting some of the character likenesses
really just being able to capture you
know every angle of the character every
angle of the costume and really being
able to accurately recreate that in a
digital sculpt once the reference photos
are chosen the real fun begins we will
take these types of images and we'll
send them down to our model shop and
they will
take these into different programs cut
them apart and reconfigure them I can
show you that we use our 3d modeling
software and in here we take all the
photo reference they've give
us zoom in get all these details we
create multiple layers and we just kind
of go in here we start refining
different shapes different colors the
sculptors use the reference photos and
the already crafted head sculpts to
digitally recreate the actors and paint
their face onto the digital sculpt when
I get the head in it's actually just
like a plain blank white head and then
from there I add all the colors I'm just
constantly going back and forth between
the reference and the sculpt and
painting and try to recreate it the
artist might add some blush refine the
eyes increase the overall saturation
basically making sure any detail in the
actor's face is mirrored in the figure
anywhere that we feel like we want to
accentuate his brow line he's kind of
has a serious look so I put some shading
in there so when it prints it really
accentuates the sculpt
once the face is finished it's printed
onto the head sculpt finally the
sculptor will assemble the different
parts of the figure and paint the non
photo real parts will prime this out the
whole figure will base out the figure
then we'll start doing all the hand
painting all the details we've got our
green here so just going in hand
painting all those details and then by
the end of it we've got a fully painted
model because the process is so new and
secretive there were a few things Hasbro
couldn't show us but once the model is
complete Hasbro its manufacturing
partners the license or and the actor
all work together to make sure everyone
loves both the figure and the packaging
it will come in and a few months after
everyone signs off on it it's ready for
store shelves
[Music]